touche les États-Unis par le sud-ouest
de la Floride vue depuis l'espace
l'ouragan de catégorie 4 sur 5 emporte
tout sur son passage manifestation qui
ont eu lieu un petit peu partout en
France aujourd'hui pour les salaires et
contre la réforme des retraites
vous savez quoi le mieux c'est que je
revienne par ici
et Emmanuel Macron qui pour son conseil
national de la refondation
s'inspire avec le CNR du Conseil
National de la Résistance en fait est en
train de détruire tout ce qu'a construit
le Conseil National de la Résistance ici
c'est un requin que le courant a mené
hors de son habitat naturel la question
des salaires allait poser dans ce pays
depuis le début de l'année il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de grève et d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui il y a des centaines de
milliers de salariés qui ont arrêté le
travail donc on pense que c'est une
première étape et parlons-en projet
contre projet les Français veulent être
consultés par référendum organisons un
tel référendum sur une réforme des
retraites il faut que Macron il ait peur
du mouvement social il faut que les
capitalistes ils aient peur du mouvement
social et c'est ça l'essentiel pour nous
parce que sinon on n'arrête pas de
commenter ce que fait Macron toute façon
Macron il fait n'importe quoi et puis
Macron il est obsédé par par servir les
plus riches désormais une quatrième
fuite détectée par les autorités
suédoises sans qu'on sache si elle
n'avait pas encore été observer ou si
c'est une nouvelle fuite est donc
potentiellement un nouveau sabotage hier
soir le président
aquama 1100 euros la prise en compte de
la pénibilité et la suppression des
régimes spéciaux c'est une réforme
indispensable qui nécessite du courage
mais cette réforme est indispensable
demain pour sauver notre système de
retraite une réforme dans le cadre d'un
projet de loi mais pour apaiser les
dissensions au sein même de la majorité
le gouvernement va rouvrir les
concertations oui avec deux phrases clés
du président s'il y a une motion de
censure qui est votait je dissout tout
de suite voilà ce qu'il a dit hier soir
majorité à l'Élysée en rajoutant je ne
veux surtout pas la chanlie si une
motion de censure est adoptée tout le
monde repart en campagne Macron rêve de
se draper dans l'habit du général tous
les jours mais excusez-moi il est plutôt
au niveau du caporal quoi aujourd'hui
voilà et tout ça en réalité il y a pas
de sur ligne il y a la démocratie la
menace de la dissolution nucléaire de
faire exploser l'Assemblée nationale si
sa réforme de retraite qui prévoit
demander aux Français de travailler près
d'un demi-siècle pour avoir droit à leur
retraite voter une motion de censure si
toutes les oppositions squalisées pour
adopter une notion de censure et faire
tomber le gouvernement il s'en remettrai
aux Français et les Français
trancheraient et dirait quelle est la
nouvelle majorité qu'ils veulent Marine
Le Pen qui a réagi sur Twitter et qui
met simplement chiche on a aussi la
réaction de Mathilde de panneaux qui
elle écrit quand vous voulez la nuque
est prête à vous défaire c'est surtout
pour les macronistes que c'est une
menace non c'est pas moi je prends pas
ça pour une menace
c'est une opportunité et à la tête de la
radicalisation sur ces sujets nous avons
une députée
écolo qui est Madame Rousseau et qui
veut faire flamber tout quoi
si c'est ça je dis ça vous aurez plus
votre mandat de député bah moi je suis
retourné vers les électeurs électriques
du 13e arrondissement de Paris et voilà
j'en serais très heureuse on reprend une
campagne
peut-être quelqu'un au pilori
publiquement sens que nous sachions ni
qu'elles sachent ce qui s'est passé des
deux côtés de toute façon ça serait pas
à elle de le faire mais à la campagne
le président américain interpelle Jackie
waorski une républicaine pourtant
décédée au début du mois d'août Joe
Biden était bien au courant de son décès
puisqu'il s'était dit choqué et attristé
dans un communiqué et qu'il doit
rencontrer sa famille ce vendredi et en
tout cas ça fait beaucoup rire les
internautes regardez ce tweet que j'aime
beaucoup qui nous a donné Victor
Estrangin sobriété
Christophe Messi
le conflit de plus laver les cheveux
pour faire des économies d'énergie